Narrator:
JAMIE'S DECIDED TO GET GNARLY.
Jamie:
THE SURFBOARD CAME TOGETHER
PRETTY MUCH THE WAY
THAT I HAD PLANNED.
IT'S FOUR PONTOONS
THAT ARE ALL TAPED TOGETHER
INTO ONE BIG THING
THAT IS THE SIZE AND SHAPE
OF A SURFBOARD, MORE OR LESS,
AND I IMAGINE
IT'LL WORK LIKE ONE.
TIME TO GO SURFING.
Narrator: DESPITE THE OPTIMISM,
THERE IS A MAJOR DRAWBACK.
Jamie: OH, LOOK AT THAT!
Narrator: JAMIE'S NEVER SURFED
IN HIS LIFE.
[ LAUGHS ]
Narrator:
AND LEARNING ON A SLIGHTLY LEAKY
DUCT-TAPE SURFBOARD
WAS NEVER GOING TO BE
PLAIN SAILING.
Jamie: HEY!
[ LAUGHS ]
[ EXHALES SHARPLY ]
HERE WE GO!
WELL, THAT WAS EXHAUSTING.
BUT I'M ACTUALLY KIND OF HAPPY
WITH IT BECAUSE I LEARNED
THAT WHILE DUCT TAPE IS OKAY
AT SEALING THINGS UP,
IT'S NOT PERFECT, AND
EVENTUALLY, STUFF'S GONNA LEAK.
OHHH!
[ LAUGHING ]
SO, IF YOU BUILT SOMETHING
THAT'S RELYING
ON A SEALED PONTOON,
THEN YOU'RE SCREWED BECAUSE
YOU'VE GOT NO ABILITY TO BAIL IT
OR EMPTY IT OUT IN ANY WAY,
AND IT'S GONNA SINK.
SO, FAILURE AS A SURFBOARD, YES,
BUT SUCCESS AS AN EXPERIMENT.